you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess calm
right now and I just got done going
through several tactics trainer puzzles
and I'd like to share three of them with
you so as usual with this type of video
feel free to treat it as a mini pop quiz
I'll go through the answers and offer
some brief tips along the way so in this
first one white to move feel free to
pause the video and see if you can find
the best continuation all right
solution to this first one is to play
route 2 g8 we have to be very direct and
you should be able to come up with that
knowing that given a move black will
have some threats of his own rook B for
King a1 and then Bishop to b2 Bishop a3
black will at the very least have a
perpetual check we need to be direct in
fact this is a million-five puzzle the
correct first move as mentioned is rook
g8 let me just squash one other checking
move Knight f7 does not work because
after rook takes Knight rook g8 the only
check in the position after King h7
there simply isn't a good follow-up
check both rook checks on g7 are covered
by the rook as well as the knight check
on f6 and the only other move Knight g5
well that cuts off the communication
between both rooks King takes rook and
black will go on to win so the correct
solution here is to first start with
rook g8 and now there are two options on
rook takes rook we would have a mate in
two very nice mate 9 f7 and knight on f6
is checkmate and the other variation is
at this point after rook g8 and this is
really the main one that needed to be
calculated King age 7 rook 1 to g7
inviting a new piece into the attack
this forces King takes Knight and now we
need to get the knight working and he's
on an opposite color of the King but we
can force the King to a light Square in
this case with rook g6
and now no matter where the King goes
the knight will be able to deliver a
check next King h7 Knight g5 is May and
lastly King takes pawn is met with
Knight g3 King h4 and now Brooke on g6
to h6 for mate so I thought that that
one was a cool sequence there let's have
a look at another one in endgame one
this one right here where we are now
playing as team black once more if you'd
like to go ahead pause the video see if
you can find the best continuation
okay solution here is to capture the
rook and after rook takes rook to
deliver another check so both moves here
first they capture and now I check very
direct stuff it does not end there after
king d2 we now have the key idea and
that is to play c3 what is this doing
it's of course giving check and it's
also creating some more tension with the
Queen side pawns now what this is going
to result in is a passed pawn whether
white likes that are not this is going
to happen on a king move we would have
on Tanks pawn and black will soon
promote and on pawn takes pawn
we don't recapture on c3 but instead
capture on a3 so what is white to do
here well there's one last little trick
now for team white and that is to give
this check and the last important note
of this puzzle is to know what square
you go to with your King the correct
move is to play to f8 and there will now
be no way for white to stop the a pawn
is just not going to be there in time
well it sacrifice himself for the Queen
but the rook is of course they're
watching over a1 what is the issue with
black going to the corner do know that
now black is in some hot water just a
moment away now from getting mated as
soon as the rook moves there is now not
time to advance this pawn because you'd
be getting checkmated so that was the
key idea and really the important tip
here with this particular endgame well
regarding the pawns really is that when
you create this type of tension you know
black hand force through a passed pawn
when this h6 move is
so if you just kind of ignore everything
on this puzzle right here except for
just the pawns when a three is played
black hand forced through a passed pawn
with this right here again assuming
there's no other pieces here no matter
what white does in reply to c3 capturing
like this we saw there's this recapture
black has a passed pawn a push we just
capture what other sequences are there a
capture here results in this type of
capture once more a passed pawn so to be
very delicate maybe a better move here
to make sure there isn't that kind of
passed pawn being created on the black
end you could stop things cold by
advancing the b3 pawn I'm not in any way
saying that this is the best move but
that's a good way to kind of prevent any
type of past pawn from being created you
advance that middle pond where it has
support of both white pawns and the hon
just a little endgame tip there
regarding the pawns a3 as it turns out
it's a very bad move in a hip forcefully
c3 coming in with check okay one last
one
this one right here playing his team
light if you'd like to go ahead pause
the video see if you can find the best
continuation
okay I really like this one those of you
that spent some time trying to work this
for now I hope you got it
because it's one that makes you feel
good we have every well let's just say
it like this aside from the king and
both Queen side pawns every other white
piece is involved in this checkmate in
eight you ready for this one every piece
every pawn plays a role aside from the
Queen side pawns and the king in this
one it's pretty cool to see this one in
action here we go
Queen takes Knight this is the only win
need to eliminate and eliminate that
night why if you try something else like
a bishop check or a queen check there is
a knight block on f7 so the key idea
here is to first eliminate that
potential block on f7
rook takes Queen is best if the king is
just running out now we could give a
check and we'll be giving mate soon
enough
rook block bishop takes four mate okay
of course we take the Queen in this
position after Queen takes Knight but
now what is the follow-up well now we
give the check with the bishop
there are only moves like Rocha d5 and
rip to e6 might as well just put them on
the board delaying what is soon to be a
checkmate and eight King in the corner
what is now the key idea well Knight g6
pawn takes knight on takes pawn discover
check this Knight can now block but we
capture him because in the end after
pawn takes Bishop we now have a
fantastic finish both bishops and its
little pawn on g6 delivering checkmate I
guess in the end I misspoke a little bit
I guess this pawn on g3 doesn't really
play a role either but yeah every piece
aside from the king is involved in this
checkmate an eighth one that's worth
having a look at once more queen sac
bishop check well yeah aside from the
rook blocks we just dive right in there
Knight g6 pawn takes Knight block we
just take and double bishops bishops
working on adjacent diagonals very
valuable very deadly as we see here okay
well as usual feel free to share how you
did with these three I found them
interesting I hope you did as well feel
free to leave any feedback in the
comment section below and I will catch
you in the next video that's all for now
take care bye
you
[Music]